alright dr. Kevin Porteous is assistant
professor of politics at Hillsdale
College and faculty advisor for the
Washington Hillsdale internship program
here in his BA at Ashland University and
his MA and PhD in politics from the
Institute of philosophic studies at the
university of dallas previously he
taught at belmont abbey college near
charlotte north carolina and Mountain
View college in Dallas Texas recently he
completed a book manuscript executive
details public administration and
American constitutionalism publication
of which is forthcoming please join me
in welcoming dr. Kevin Porteous
I'm under orders
good morning I'd like to thank the the
kirby center and dr. bob its director
and hillsdale college for giving me the
opportunity to come and speak to you
today about the question is there a
place for regulatory agencies in the
Constitution I suppose that something of
a leading question we have at least some
idea of where you should have at least
some idea of where I'm going to be going
with this today and it's not any
surprise to anyone who's familiar with
the work of the college and our
understanding of the Constitution the
American Founding that modern regulatory
agencies occupy a very tenuous place
within the American political order and
I'd like to support that assertion by
referring to three specific
constitutional issues the first of which
is the broad doctrine of the separation
of powers about which senator Lee spoke
in his talk second is the non delegation
doctrine the idea that legislative power
belongs to the legislature again we're
going to do some expansion and talking
about that and then finally the
executives power of removal which is
something that's not particularly well
understood but proves to be vital to
maintaining the separation of power
structure of the American Constitution
with regards to administration now first
with the separation of powers the
separation of powers is the central
structural feature of the Constitution
federalism is there the idea of a large
republic is there the idea of limited
government those are all there but when
one looks at the Constitution itself the
text itself is organized around the idea
that that different powers and different
branches belong in different places that
they should be separated from one
another and the first purpose of this
obviously is to prevent tyranny by
preventing the accumulation of power in
a single set of hands and Madison is
very clear about this in Federalist 47
that the accumulation of power in one
set of hands no matter what set of hands
it might be is by definition tyrannical
and so later on in federalist 51 he
tells us that human nature is enlisted
to keep the branches in line he says
quote the constant aim is to divide and
arrange the several offices
in such manner as that each may be a
check on the other that the private
interest of every individual may be a
sentinel over the public rights we are
using the human nature of office holders
who want to maintain their power and who
want to maintain their position in order
to maintain the overall efficacy of the
whole structure and this is absolutely
true and it's vital but I would suggest
to you that there is a second purpose to
the separation of powers one that is
often overlooked and I think imperfectly
understood but is at least as important
as the function of preventing tyranny
and that's the role that the separation
of powers plays in promoting good or
promoting effective government we don't
typically think of the constitutional
order as being meant to facilitate the
effective operation of the government we
tend to think of the Constitution in the
separation of power system as throwing
up roadblocks and in some ways it does
but in other ways it is acutely
conscious of the fact that it's
essential if you are going to have
practical Liberty if Liberty is actually
going to exist that you not just
organize a good Constitution and have
good laws but that those laws be
effectively and justly implemented right
it does no good for example to hire a
very excellent architect to design a
wonderful building such as the building
we're all standing in today and then
hire the three stooges to build it all
right what you get is the three stooges
beat each other with two by fours for
six months and then you have nothing the
plan was fantastic but the
implementation was poor and if the
implementation is poor then the plan for
all practical purposes is irrelevant so
the thing has to function effectively as
well and they were conscious of this in
Federalist 48 Madison makes the point
that power rather than being a single
mass for the founding fathers was
partitioned into powers in the plural he
said after discriminating therefore in
theory the several classes of power as
they may be in their nature legislative
executive or
judiciary unquote then and only then can
we go on to talk about organizing the
branches themselves so that the first
and most important task of setting up a
constitutional order is figuring out
what the powers are and Madison
statement I think very clearly states
that there is something substantively
different about legislative power that
separates it from executive power
they're not the same thing and so what
it takes to execute effectively is
fundamentally different from what it
takes to legislate effectively and so we
need separate and distinct institutions
in order to do that Alexander Hamilton
points out in Federalist 70 for example
that unity in the executive is as
essential as multiplicity in the
legislature from the in the executive in
the president we want decisive swift
action whereas when laws are being made
and our rights and duties under the law
are being decided we want different
interests and different ideas to be
heard we want that body to deliberate to
think to act slowly and so it becomes
apparent fairly quickly that no one
institution can do both of those things
well simply as a matter of physical
reality if you are a unitary body you
cannot at the same time be a body
composed of multiple members and so if
you are constructed to legislate
effectively than by definition you are
not an institution that can execute
effectively nevertheless if one examines
modern administrative agencies one
notices very quickly that it is
precisely to do all of these things at
once that moderate administrative
agencies attempt so let me let me give
you an example all right and this is
this has taken from a very prominent
Harvard Law article 20 years ago he
called the rise and rise of the
administrative state right he says the
author Gary Lawson says consider the
typical enforcement activities of a
typical federal
see but for example the Federal Trade
Commission the Commission promulgates
substantive rules of conduct the
Commission then considers whether to
authorize investigations into whether
the Commission's rules have been
violated if the Commission authorizes an
investigation the investigation is
conducted by the Commission which
reports its findings to the Commission
if the Commission thinks that the
Commission's findings warrant an
enforcement action the Commission issues
a complaint the Commission's complaint
that a competi Commission rule has been
violated is then prosecuted by the
Commission and adjudicated by the
Commission this commission adjudication
can take place either before the full
commission or before a semi-autonomous
administrative law judge who is an
employee of the Commission if the
Commission chooses to adjudicate before
an administrative law judge rather than
before the Commission and the decision
is adverse to the Commission the
Commission can then appeal to the
Commission if the Commission ultimately
finds a violation then and only then the
affected private party can appeal to an
article three court but the agency
decision even before a bona fide article
three tribunal possesses a very strong
presumption of correctness on matters
both a fact and of law right and so we
laugh about this right but the laughter
I think only masks right the scale of
the constitutional problem here right
which is simply write the assumption
that we can create an institution right
that is different from all of the
institutions that are set up by the
Constitution and that that it somehow
can perform not just one function right
of the federal government but all of
them simultaneously and do it more
effectively and more justly than the
separated system which recognizes the
substantive difference between the
powers and I'd like what I'd like to do
next then is to take a brief look at two
examples of how separation of powers
works as it relates to administrate
agencies and the first of these as I
noted at the outset was the non
delegation doctrine now the first
substantive Clause of the Constitution
says that all legislative powers herein
granted shall be vested in a congress of
the united states which shall consist of
a Senate and of a House of
Representatives and this is what's
referred to as the legislative vesting
clause and the implications of that
statement are fairly simple if the power
is legislative and it is constitutional
that is to say later on this is the
herein granted part the Constitution
enumerates a list of things that the
federal legislature can do it can't do
anything that might be legislative it
can do those things that are legislative
that are listed later on in the
Constitution right so if it is a
legislative power and it is
constitutional then it must be exercised
by Congress so the political philosopher
John Locke notes that Congress cannot
transfer this power and he says quote
the legislative cannot transfer the
power of making laws to any other hands
for it being but a delegated power from
the people they who have it cannot pass
it over to others only the people can
decide where to place the legislative
power and in the Constitution they have
placed that power in Congress Justice
Scalia in one of his more biting
dissents notes that when Congress
transfers its power to other entities it
has the effect of creating what he what
he calls quote junior varsity
legislators we have a problem it's
complicated it's politically divisive so
we create institution and let them
legislate on that particular area right
and we have hundreds of these floating
around Washington DC okay so Congress
can't transfer this power no power is
granted to Congress to create additional
legislative entities Congress must
exercise this power for its for itself
but that then gives rise to the question
what is the legislative power
right and my students are very quick
with the answer it's the power to make
laws and then I'm very quick with the
counter question all right what's the
law and then silence right and that's a
little more difficult as founders had
something to say about this right
Alexander Hamilton in Federalist 75
notes that the legislative power is the
power to prescribe rules for the
regulation of society Hamilton or excuse
me James Madison in his essay vices of
the political system of the United
States says that the legislative power
is the power to mark with precision the
duties of those who are to obey them and
to take from those who are to administer
them a discretion which might be abused
so if we can translate those statements
and there are many others like them
right give you one more Madison and
federer in Federalist 62 says that law
is defined to be a rule of action but
how can that be a rule which is little
known and less fixed and to reinforce
the idea of little known depressing fact
that I like to share with my students is
that there's a there's a book a
publication of the federal government
called the Federal Register right and
this is the journal of all the new and
proposed regulations that the federal
government the federal agency this is
not Congress mind you comes up with in a
given calendar year and it starts every
January first a new volume starts at
page one and in a given year by December
31st federal government is somewhere in
the range of seventy to eighty thousand
pages and this is in addition to all of
the previous still existing regulations
right and the United States Code which
is the law enacted by Congress right if
you ever have a chance to look at the
Federal Register it's in that wonderful
government print too it's like reading
your tax return for eighty thousand
pages right at any rate alright so how
do we translate these assertions about
the meaning of law
law I think must make substantive policy
choices that is to say it must reflect
the Legislature's judgment concerning
what ought to be the rights and duties
of citizens and in that vein right it
must clearly delineate those rights and
those duties it must tell people what is
permitted under the law what is required
under the law and what is prohibited
under the law in such a way that you and
I as well informed citizens can read the
law and understand it and understand
what our what are our rights and duties
under the law that is to say law must be
sufficiently clear that its commands are
plainly discernible to citizens now i
would suggest by the way that if you
take it take a quick look at federal
laws take for example the 2500 page
health care reform bill all right that's
literally I like to point out my
students 5 reams of paper in that
wonderful government language and we
certain parts of it draw a great deal of
criticism for example the individual
mandate we all know about the individual
mandate the idea that the government is
going to compel us to purchase health
insurance and purchase health insurance
of a certain quality you're certain kind
and it that's something that's before
the Supreme Court right now and it has
clear constitutional issues right but
one of the things that becomes apparent
when you start reading the law is that
for the most part it doesn't tell you
anything it simply says this agency or
this official will make this rule right
and it leaves it to someone else right
rather than making the decision for
itself right so for example just
recently the Department of Health and
Human Services has decreed that
religious employers must cover
contraception at no cost for their
employees as part of their employee
health plan this has been the subject of
at least a couple of law
suits in mostly involving religiously
based colleges and universities one of
which is my former employer the
individual mandate is problematic but
the real long-term nightmare of the
health care law from a constitutional
perspective right is the fact that these
kind of policy decisions are made by
people other than the United States
Congress right other than legislators
who are specifically elected to do that
specific job right and that's the kind
of thing right those kinds of orders
from federal agencies from cabinet
officials those are the kind of things
that are really rules for the regulation
of society but in broad terms the health
care law mostly says we want everyone to
have quality affordable health care now
you cabinet officials and you edit
agencies that we're creating or
empowering you tell us what we have to
do in order to achieve that right and
you make the rules for the regulation of
society things that actually affect
people's rights and duties right the
things that tell people this is
permitted this is required this is
prohibited if an agency or an executive
branch official is doing that then
whatever we call it then they are
legislating they are exercising the
legislative power let me give you one
more example right in the previous
Congress right the 1st Congress under
the Obama administration the health care
law was enacted right but the
environmental regulation or
environmental proposal commonly known as
cap and trade died it pass through the
house but was unable to clear the Senate
for a variety of reasons mostly
agricultural and coal state senators
were not interested in committing
political suicide even Democratic ones
after the election in 2010 President
Obama said something to the effect of
well there's more than one way to skin
that cat we're looking into other
options and use that language during
there's a press conference and
what he meant by that was we weren't
able to get this done through the
legislative process so we're going to do
it through the regulatory process and
that's exactly what we're doing all
right the Environmental Protection
Agency is implementing if not the exact
features of cap and trade then its
substantive provisions that is to say
the substantive impact that it will have
on American business on American economy
on American workers through the
regulatory process and this Congress and
many of the people who voted for them
are coming to the stunning realization
that when you have delegation the
reality is elections don't matter it
doesn't matter that 63 Democratic
members of the House of Representatives
disappeared in the election of 2010 and
were replaced by Republicans right net
it doesn't matter right that voters sent
an apparently unambiguous message that's
all irrelevant because they can all be
done through the regulatory process in
substance if not an exact form so we're
getting a series of new federal
regulations on a variety of things
carbon emissions mercury is the new one
that's coming out this week I suppose I
should note the obvious irony of the
Environmental Protection Agency imposing
new caps on mercury when at the same
time the federal government is
compelling all of us to introduce
mercury gas into our own homes through
the recently not recently enacted but a
requirement that recently took effect in
light bulb emissions that is essentially
going to mandate compact fluorescent
light bulbs which do contain mercury gas
at any rate in these cases and every
other entities other than Congress are
exercising legislative authority and in
every single instance it is with the
permission of congress congress passed
the laws that transfer this authority
and so in a way and i think this is
heresy to say this but in a way i almost
feel sorry for regulators at
because they do have a difficult task
they have to make these political
hot-button decisions without the support
of anything like an election to back
them up a congressman can at least say
my constituents want X and if he's right
he'll get reelected and if he's wrong he
won't regulators can't do that right the
real root problem is with Congress right
Congress enacted these laws and could
unen act them at any time now this is
not to say that delegation does not have
the blessing of the other institutions
of government for example 20 years ago
the Supreme Court asserted that our
jurisprudence has been driven by a
practical understanding that in our
increasingly complex society replete
with ever-changing and more technical
problems Congress simply cannot do its
job absent and ability to delegate power
under broad general directives right the
world is too hard now for citizen
legislators right even ones who are
intelligent patriotic and committed to
the Constitution and again so long as
Congress delineates an intelligible
principle then it can delegate right and
by intelligible principle they mean
something for the effect of we can
understand what they're trying to do
when it comes up for judicial review
right now what are some examples of
intelligible principles that have passed
constitutional muster the law that
created the Federal Communications
Commission states that the Federal
Communications Commission is to regulate
broadcast licensing quote as public
interest convenience or necessity
require unquote which in effect means
anything the agency thinks is relevant
the Americans with Disabilities Act
mandates that employers and educators
must make quote reasonable
accommodations what constitutes a
reasonable accommodation typically one
doesn't know until one is told by a
judge which is after the fact and that
employers and educators cannot impose an
undue
ship again what does that mean the
regulators and and the judges are going
to tell us eventually back to the health
care law the Secretary of Health and
Human Services and I know this hasn't
passed constitutional muster but it's a
wonderful example the Secretary of
Health and Human Services can determine
what constitute essential health
benefits that must be offered by
employers as part of their health
coverage now shouldn't what constitutes
assuming of course that Congress can
enact health care legislation of this
kind in the first place okay doesn't it
seem as though essential would be a
determination that a legislature should
make and that in making that
determination in reaching those
conclusions one is going to decide rules
for the regulation of society all right
so if one compares the constitutional
order and the modern regulatory state
one sees many advantages in the former
Congress was specially designed to
legislate effectively an agency however
it's constitute it can only be a poor
shadow in terms of the structural
quality of the institution very quick
way of understanding that is your
legislature is elected every two years
or six years but nobody votes for an
agency and that electoral process
specifically designed in the
Constitution was meant to contribute to
the quality of deliberation all right
legislators secondly must consider the
general interest because they are
elected by their districts or their
states as a whole and not simply by one
particular interest group within that
district or state whereas agencies right
are disproportionately influenced by the
various interests which they regulate
why well with that that's simple because
the regulators are concentrated right
here in Washington and it's an easy
thing for a lobbyist and interest an
industry or a public interest group to
send its people over here to influence
regulators
a congressman has to look at an
environmental interest group and say yes
I understand your concerns but I also
have this other issue to deal with which
is the people in my district need to
work right and so I have to think about
both of those things a regulator does
not and in many cases is statutorily
prohibited from taking those other
factors into account when Congress does
the legislating there are limits to the
quantity of legislation that gets passed
one legislature can only do so much as a
matter of physical reality on the other
hand when you can simply create more
legislators you can simply create more
opportunity to make laws and so you have
eighty thousand pages a year of new
regulations in addition to all pre
existing laws it curtails the problem of
vague or contradictory legislation
Congress is is capable of being
contradictory Zeni buddy else but when
you have hundreds of legislators the
possibility of being told to do two
different and incompatible things at the
same time is lessened so the lightbulb
example you're less likely to have that
problem if you have one group of people
making the laws finally and perhaps most
importantly there is a union of power
and responsibility the people who
exercise the legislative power are held
accountable for it under the modern
system Congress takes credit for the
benefits it creates we gave you clean
air we gave you quality affordable
health care while passing responsibility
for the costs it imposes off onto in
many cases hapless regulators whom
congressman then turn around and condemn
right the same congressmen who voted to
give that power to the agency in the
first place it's very convenient for the
Congress okay so that much by way of
problems of delegation and the
legislative power the final topic I'd
like to talk to you a little bit about
today is the executive removal power
right the power that the president has
under the Constitution to fire those who
were
in the executive branch and this is a
difficult one I think especially for
people who are interested in the
Constitution and limited government
because the removal power the power to
fire is not explicitly delineated in the
Constitution the appointment power is
article 2 section 2 the Constitution
very plainly states the modes by which
executive officers under the president
can be hired however the removal power
is left somewhat to inference so the
Constitution is silent on the removal
power but it creates a unitary executive
branch so the executive vest in clause
the president's counterpart to the
legislative vesting Clause States the
executive power shall be vested in a
president of the United States of
America two important considerations
here President of the United States of
America one person secondly the
executive power as opposed to all
legislative power herein granted in
other words we're not going to give you
a list of the things that the executive
can do that's exhaustive we're going to
tell you that the executive power as a
body with certain exceptions and
qualifications that are stated in the
Constitution is granted to the president
and consistent with the overall systems
of separation of powers individual
liberty and so on this includes I
believe the power to fire those who work
under the president Madison tells the
first Congress who had to decide this
issue in creating the cabinet quote i
conceive that if any power whatsoever is
in its nature executive it is the power
of appointing overseeing and controlling
those who execute the laws right unlike
congress which can do the legislating
for itself the nature of executive power
is such that the president can't do it
all himself he can't be sitting at the
dock at the Port of New York waiting for
the ships to come in to collect the
customs duties and right be off in
Arizona prosecuting a tax violation he
can't do it all at once he needs
extra pairs of eyes and extra pairs of
hands and that's the way right the
founders referred to people who worked
under the president they were his eyes
in his hands right Hamilton and federal
is 72 calls them deputies or assistance
of the chief magistrate okay so the
problem is if the president can't
control the people who are exercising
executive power how can he be held
responsible for it how can we say that
the president has the executive power if
he has no control over those whose hands
and eyes are actually on the scene
exercising executive power another
member of Congress Benjamin goodhue said
it was the peculiar duty of the
president to watch over executive
officers but of what a veil would be his
inspection unless he had a power to
correct the abuses he might discover and
the ultimate check on the power of those
subordinate administrators is the power
that the president possessed to fire
them and then to hire somebody right
through the appointment process who
would do things the way the president
wanted them done and not only is this
vital for maintaining the form of the
Constitution maintaining the way the
Constitution understands well the
president should have this power but
it's absolutely vital to maintaining the
connection between executive power and
the people it's not just the lawmaking
power that is meant to be popular all
power under the Constitution is meant to
be ultimately controlled by the people
either directly or indirectly so another
interesting quote from Madison at about
the same time he says if the president
should possess alone the power of
removal from office those who are
employed in the execution of the law
will be in their proper situation and
the chain of dependence be preserved the
lowest officers the middle grade and the
highest will depend as they ought on the
president and the president on the
community the chain of defense
dependence there
for terminates in the supreme body
namely in the people we choose a
president or at least it was originally
understood that we should choose a
president with the idea that he would be
the chief executive because we wanted
that person to be in charge of the
execution of the laws right and what
that means in practice is that we want
him to put people in place who will
execute the law the way that we wanted
it executed and then if we don't like
the way he's executed it is executed
excuse me we can replace them by
replacing the president so that
ultimately however indirect the process
maybe the people still control the
executive power just like they control
the legislative power now I would argue
that the modern regulatory agency very
distinctly severs this link in two
different ways right you have regulatory
commissions like the Federal
Communications Commission or the federal
election commission and the
commissioners on those agencies serve
fixed terms and they can only be removed
for cause that is to say political
disagreement about how to execute the
law with the elected president cannot be
used as a basis for removing one of
these commissioners secondly most
federal employees and most federal
employees are in the executive branch
technically most federal employees are
covered over by Civil Service protection
it's a wonderful little cartoon that I
like to share with my students from The
New Yorker and it shows to bureaucrats
sitting at their desks next to each
other and there's a window between them
in the background you can see the White
House all right and one of them looks at
the other and says just think about it
ad presidents come and go but we're
forever and that's the reality of the
civil service all right most of the
people who exercise executive power in
the details on a day-to-day basis are
insulated and consciously so from
political control
so that again just like with non
delegation elections don't matter we
elect a new president and in many ways
the agency's just keep humming along as
though nothing ever happened because
it's the same personnel the same people
and even if a president nominates and
sends over to an agency a director a
commissioner cabinet secretary or so on
it's extremely difficult for that person
to get control of that agency and in
many cases this Nixon like to complain
the new director himself would go native
let us say end up siding with the agency
he'd been sent to rein in which is
extremely problematic from the
perspective of a constitution which is
meant to preserve representative
government right effective control by
the people over all of the functions of
government this arrangement the
Commissioner structure in particular was
ratified by the Supreme Court many years
ago very famous case called Humphries
executor versus United States the court
says the Commission is to be nonpartisan
and the commissioning question here is
the Federal Trade Commission the
aforementioned Federal Trade Commission
and it must from the nature of its very
nature of its duties act with entire
impartiality it is charged with the
enforcement of no policy except the
policy of the law now I would be very
grateful if someone would explain to me
how that's not executive power the
policy that they enforces the policy of
the law and that sounds like the
enforcement power of the executive to me
but somehow and with no explanation
that's different according to the court
here like the Interstate Commerce
Commission its members are called upon
to exercise the trained judgment of a
body of experts appointed by law and
informed by experience in other words
what we hear today consider a bug of the
system of having independent
commissioners the court at this time and
as my colleague dr. distrito will
discuss in his in his talk afterwards I
believe this was a feature of the system
this independence we want to harness
this expertise uncorrupted by politics
and you can see examples of the problem
in action think about the multitudinous
security leaks within the Bush
administration right it seemed like
every week or every month some new bit
of information that wasn't supposed to
be public comes oozing out of an
administrative agency usually related to
the intelligence and defence fields well
what happened we've got a bunch of
people in there who are holdovers from
previous administrations who are
philosophically and ideologically
opposed to the new administration and so
they're going to do what they can in
their position to sabotage their
opponent now if the president could come
in and clean house you'd have something
of a different story all right so what
are the consequences practical
consequences of the evisceration of the
executive removal power you have the
creation of what what is referred to
repeatedly of a headless fourth branch
there's a there's a struggle within
within the government for control of
these agencies you have an entirely new
entity and the elected branches fight
over it Congress wants control the
president wants control right and the
consequence is not only do laws get made
worse or in an inferior manner than they
were under the Constitution but they get
implemented more in effectively as well
the other problem is the same problem
you have with delegation which is to say
eliminating the executive removal power
severs the link between the power of an
individual and his responsibility to the
people Congress which now ultimately
controls the administration in the
absence of an effective removal power
escapes blame Congress uses its
budgetary power now to control agencies
administrators themselves are insulated
from public control and the president
who gets the blame or at least a large
portion of the blame can do nothing
about it so what I've tried to do then
is to delineate some specifics
looking to the actual text of the
Constitution and working through some of
its implications of how it is that the
administrative state is constitutionally
problematic modern regulatory agency
agencies I would conclude are
incompatible with both the text and
theory of the Constitution and therefore
have no place in the political system
created by the Constitution thank you
all very much for listening
so we have our first question please my
name is jeiza Watsky I come from
Bethesda Maryland you have well
described the problems and why
essentially these administrative
agencies are unconstitutional but what
is the answer is it just simply to zero
out their budgets you want solutions I'm
the problems man hey no that's obviously
that's the challenging next step is how
do we how do we deal with this problem
and I can tell you at the very least
some ways we can't deal with it right
one one person who's written on this
issue in great detail former National
Resources Defense Council attorney named
David show and brought who turned on the
administrative state later on realized
its problems he said his proposal was
let's do it through the judiciary the
courts need to come in and enforce these
doctrines and one of the things that
we've learned and if you think about the
court cases that I've cited in the
course of my talk is the judiciary is
basically checked out on these issues
they're not interested the case dealing
with delegation where they signed off on
it 20 years ago they revisited it 10
years ago in the words of another
administrative law scholar that new
decision in 2001 which is the Whitman
trucking case can basically be boiled
down to four words go away seen the
strata the strata versus United States
was the previous case in 1989 right
that's it right so the courts aren't
going to be aren't going to solve it and
another lesson that we learned from the
Reagan administration is that the
president can't solve it even if he
wants to right he simply doesn't have
the capacity right Reagan tried right to
rein in administrative agencies and he
had some success in slowing down the
growth of the regulatory state but not
in halting it or reversing it all
together right and once he was out of
office he didn't leave any lasting
effects that is to say the pace of
regulation picked right up again to pre
Reagan levels after the Reagan
administration the president does not
possess the tools to get effective
control of the administrative state and
so that
leaves us with Congress right congress
created the thing the thing happened
over many decades and took many hundreds
of laws but but Congress created modern
regulatory agencies all of them Congress
could uncreate them by the time I sit
down if they so chose but they choose
not to do it right and I think there's a
number of reasons for that right not the
least of which is the one that I hinted
at in my talk which was that the
self-interest of congressmen is served
by the existing system they get to take
credit for the benefits right and build
credit with their voters for all the
good things they do for them we look
what I gave you right and then some
bureaucrat gets blamed for all the rules
that have to be put in place that stifle
economic growth and infringe on people's
rights that are necessary to provide the
good thing okay okay yes I gave you this
much cleaner air at the cost of but he
never says you know at the cost of
10,000 jobs in my district right so he
gets to push that off on the
administrator well the administrator
made the rule he did that right and not
only that ok but when Congress creates
all these agencies that then turn around
and create all these rules it creates a
massive minefield for citizens to wade
through and guess what people get stuck
in it and when you get stuck in the
regulatory minefield who do you call for
help you call your Congressman I just
got a mailer from my congressman right
goings on in the seventh District of
Michigan summary of that summary of
events right things that I've done in
Congress it's a campaign document that
you paid for it's all for me postage
paid by the by the taxpayers and so on
but on the back of it it has this
interesting little statement and maybe
you've seen this on something you've
gotten need help with a federal agency
are you having problem with your
benefits are you having problem with a
regulation are you not getting your
Social Security check call me I can help
right and congressmen have that power in
many cases your Congressman can help
right he can get you satisfaction right
my old department chairman was taking a
group of students to Latvia Estonia
excuse me
and two days before he was set to leave
no passport which heat applied for six
or seven months earlier call this
Congress what's going on you have the
passport the next day right when a
congressman's office calls a federal
agency the agency has an incentive to
listen and the incentive is very simple
congressman control the budgets and
money makes the world go round in
politics in regulatory politics right so
that when when the congressman calls and
says hey can you help me I'll help out
my constituent it's a very tiny price to
pay for the goodwill that it's going to
build when it comes time to generate the
next budget right so it has to be in
Congress that we find the solution but
Congress has all kinds of incentives not
to fix the problem right did most of
today's congressman create the problem
no it's been building for many decades
but do they have any incentive to fix it
also no in fact they have the perverse
counter incentive to expand it because
the more agencies career they create the
more problems people get into the more
help they need from their congressmen
and what is that what does the
congressman get from his from his
citizens as a result gets electoral
support word of mouth is still the most
powerful way that legislators build
support you should vote for this guy's
one person says to another around the
dinner table he helped me out and he
took care of me when I needed something
so again this is it this is a dilemma
right it should be in Congress that we
find the solution or it has to be in
Congress that we find the solution but
Congress has also these this perverse
set of incentives that makes them not
want to solve the problem and in many
cases to add to the problem does that
make sense that's the best answer i have
actually at this point but i have a
question from one of our online viewers
this is mike from Amherst Ohio he says I
have a very simple question how do we as
citizens effectively challenge
bureaucratic violations
the Constitution like solutions again
anyway ya know this is this is a
distinct problem because again the
courts have checked out on this issue
not only have they signed off on these
various constitutional violations right
but modern judicial doctrine states that
an administrative agency has a strong
presumption of being right when
challenged by a citizen or private group
or anything of that kind right in other
words the innocent until proven guilty
doctrine when it comes to federal
regulatory agencies is turned literally
on its head the presumption is the
agency is right and you are wrong
generally that means you're guilty until
you figure out some way to prove that
you're not guilty of the violation in
question because of that presumption of
rectitude I don't know it's a depressing
topic it really is you should see the
look on my students faces when I just
finally come to the point and say
elections don't matter and here's why
right and it just really takes the wind
out of their sails right because he'll
still students right whatever their
whatever their background or their major
right they have an interest in the
Constitution they like self-government
they like liberty and then to hear that
is is just deflating but in many ways
it's true that unless you get people
particularly into Congress who recognize
this problem and who are literally this
is a really hard thing to do literally
willing to act in a way counter to their
own immediate electoral self-interest
then it's not going to change right and
you're not going to have effective
recourse one of the most effective ways
to deal with the worst violations right
of made by the federal government today
is not through the law but through a
public relations campaign right after
the kilo case was passed having to do
with the takings clause and eminent
domain
city of Long Beach California went after
the Filipino Bible Fellowship which was
an immigrant church that met in a
double-wide trailer right most of them
didn't speak any English and so here
comes the city with its lawyers and says
here we're going to we're going to take
your land and demolish your church that
we can build a thing with condominiums
what it's shopping mall or something
doesn't really matter they didn't win in
the courts they won because they got
some pro bono legal help that consisted
of a group of attorneys who went out and
humiliated the city to the point
embarrassed look what you're doing to
these people to the point where they
back down had nothing to do with whether
the fact that right by any rational
standard the filipino bible fellowship
was in the right and had everything to
do with they had friends who could make
my life miserable for the city and so
really in many cases it boils down to do
you have influence if you have
influenced you can generally avoid the
worst effects of these of these
regulations if you don't well that's
very difficult for you then yes ma'am my
name is george and got a janome from
fairfax virginia in your presentation of
course you didn't note the massive
amounts of regulations that are now in
effect but you really didn't discuss the
fact that under the Administrative
Procedure Act an agency must go through
the rulemaking process and that rule
making process invites public
participation does that in any way
affect your conclusions about the
overarching authority of and I guess
unaccountability of federal regulators
right yes the comment system right most
federal regulations are made under a
process from the Administrative
Procedure Act known as informal
rulemaking and this is also referred to
as notice and comment rulemaking the
agency is required to post notice in the
federal register that it intends to
regulate X right it's then required to
leave a certain amount of time open for
public comment or to allow public
comment
hearing or something of that sort and
but the problem is and the reason that
it doesn't ultimately affect the outcome
or doesn't necessarily have to affect
the outcome is because what the
regulators choose to do with that
comment is entirely up to them right in
other words this is designed as a
substitute for the public input that
Congress gets through the electoral
process right but the input that
Congress gets through the electoral
process is well backed up by elections
right and the public input and the force
of public comment that regulators get is
not backed in this way right and so the
regulators can choose to do anything
they please with that information up to
include and including ignoring it all
together right let me give you an
example that's not regulatory state but
but shows you the bureaucratic mentality
at work and as in graduate school I was
teaching adjunct teaching at a community
college and the schedule was set up so
that you had classes all classes were
two day week classes Monday Wednesday
Tuesday Thursday and then a set of
Friday Saturday classes and a new
president came in and he wanted to get
rid of the Friday Saturday classes in
return to the standard monday wednesday
friday classes well district policy and
state law required that they conduct a
survey of employees and students to
gather information this they did the
overwhelming majority of both employees
and students said let's keep the current
system they switch to the other system
right that is to say the whole idea of
the comment period is something of a
farce it doesn't have to right they
don't have to do anything with that
information right thank you very much
right in the circular file we appreciate
your input see you later right they can
take they can use that information if
they want but there's no legal
requirement that they have to decide
because they're the experts they can
decide well this piece of information is
more important than that one this piece
is more true than that one and who are
we to question them right in the case of
the EPA right there the climatologists
they're the chemists they're the
oceanographers and meteorologists and so
on what are we
right I haven't the vaguest idea how
much benzene in the air is safe right or
sulfur dioxide I don't know okay their
dirty little secret by the way is
neither today there's gaps in the data
that we just we don't know right but the
law is set up that they have to pretend
to know and essentially what that means
in purpose in practice is that they
simply impose their own policy judgments
and then cover it over with well here's
why the data supports us okay yes ma'am
hi my name is Linda Kendall and I'm from
fairfax station virginia um I have a
question that I think it's a little bit
related it comes from a comment in the
state of the union address that
President Obama just gave which has me
very concerned and even more so after
hearing you he talked about going to
Congress to ask authority to consolidate
on the bureaucracy under the executive
what is your interpretation of that and
is there any risk or danger um in terms
of defining that quest as consolidation
of power yeah the way he described it
the way Obama described is we're going
to make the federal government leaner
and more efficient right okay there's
some chuckles in the audience there's
good reason for that right this has been
right this this this has been the the
shimmer of the presidents and congresses
have been chasing for decades all right
there have been reorganizations right
there was one during the Clinton
administration right this goes back at
least to the 1930s right with the
Brownlow Commission the President's
Committee on administrative management
right and the attempt to reorganize the
federal government in order to make it
more effective right and the simple
reality is that large government by
definition is going to be ineffective it
doesn't matter how you shuffle the cards
all right but you see that you see this
in the corporate world as well you get a
new executive in and he won
to change the organizational chart
rearranging the deckchairs as it were
all right and that often right I think
in both the corporate and government
world serves as a substitute for
actually making effective changes to the
system well if we only reorganize
everything and change the flowchart
it'll all work just fine okay now the
idea of consolidating executive power
and this does relate to my talk is a
good one right as long as what he's
consolidating is executive power the
problem is is that he wants to
consolidate control of agencies that are
also legislating and adjudicating at the
same time right that's the issue right
so one of these questions on these
arguments that we get into is which one
you do first all right do you restore
power just restore executive power to
the President or you do disentangle the
other functions from the agencies and I
have no idea how to answer that question
but yeah the government reorganization
thing it has been going on for many
decades and it really doesn't change
very much and again it's based on the
false idea that if we only again change
the flow chart that everything will be
efficient and effective right and we've
done this a number of times and it never
works yes sir the egregious
unconstitutional power grab of the
federal agencies has been well laid out
by you and cars are senator Lee but what
about the states the states also have
their own problems in terms of their
administrative agencies in are those are
incubators for democracies so is the
best way to try to reform the states and
start smaller and then build up to the
federal level writing the state's
certainly present more opportunities I
think simply because you have more of
them but you're right i mean the state
saw is the states have their problems as
well hillsdale college students love
federalism and I'll of federalism
federally the partition of power between
federal and state governments
but one of the things that we have to
remember is that the states have dropped
the ball a number of times write the
Constitution would self was formed in
large reaction to the failure of the
states to effectively protect the rights
of their citizens right majorities in
the states were using the state
mechanisms of the state governments to
expropriate other people within the
state right after the formation of the
Constitution right and for many decades
thereafter there was this there was this
peculiar institution right the states
were meant were originally intended if
you read Federals 45 is the primary
guarantors of individual rights and the
primary makers of laws that affected
individuals on a day-to-day basis right
but the states dropped the ball in the
most egregious way possible because it's
under the auspices of the states that
you have the institution of slavery I
mean so the states are not simply saying
oh well the states right that's not a
magical solution that solves the problem
either right because the state
governments are just as susceptible to
those forces as any other level of
government right but and but you can see
right that there are opportunities right
so you rein in the control of a special
interest in states like Wisconsin than
the failed attempt in Ohio and so on to
get control of their employees and so
there are possibilities in the States
but those also very largely on a
state-by-state basis some states are
more amenable to change than others
right to reform than others right some
of them i would probably put california
in this category are nearly hopeless
okay because of the the way their system
is structured the caliphate california
government is structured it makes it
very difficult to constitutionally
speaking get things back on track
this will be our final question Jane
from Exeter New Hampshire asks both
parties love to expand federal power
through administrative agencies how can
we rain in the bureaucracy when both
parties are complicit in its expansion
that's another one of those sad truth
statements I have to deliver to my
students on a regular basis right and
that simply is this is take a look
around you're watching the Republican
nomination take place we know who the
Democratic nominee is going to be and I
said ask yourself the following question
right which progressive do you want as
your next president right Newt Gingrich
Mitt Romney or Barack Obama this this
happened before the potential rise of
Rick Santorum that's that's the
situation right and that's a very
accurate description of the situation
right the the leadership in both parties
is in many ways committed to the modern
state right now right does this suggest
that a third party is what's necessary
no not necessarily as I'm not making
that argument right but it does suggest
to go back to sort of old 18th century
British understandings is that what you
have in many respects is the court party
in the country party right you have a
governing class and you have everyone
else right and many not all but many
Republicans are part of the governing
class right and this is the right this
is the result of many decades of having
a governing class and having right and
the many decades of having this
administrative state that that creates
this disconnect between the people and
those who do the governing so I haven't
I am the slightest idea how to how to
fix that all right stop voting for the
people in the court party I suppose but
that's a hard thing to tell people to do
right particularly when it comes to
Congress right people hate Congress but
they love their congressmen and I think
by the way that constituent services
aspect is a huge part of that right
as a disaster but my guy looks out for
me and so there's this cognitive
dissonance in the people right every
lots of people right the thing is an
institute is an institution is it is
disastrous all right thirteen percent
approval rating in one recent poll that
I read for the United States Congress
and yet these Congress right the
individual congressmen and so it
apparently never occurs to people when
they go to the polls that wait a minute
my congressman is part of this
institution right until you re-establish
that connection right reform certainly
if the legislative level is going to be
enormously problematic right getting
people in you saw some you saw some
glimmers of that I think you know people
like Senator Lee or certainly a step in
the right direction but we need more of
those people and that demands in the end
a more educated public right in the end
it comes down to write in many respects
a civic education project right if the
people are going to rule in washington
says in his farewell address if public
opinion is going to govern then public
opinion has to be enlightened all right
like to thank you all very much for your
attendance and participation
you